interviews ever was with et canada oh is
that
brothers and sisters brothers and
sisters when you go back in your mind to
that time i believe you came out during
that show
to where you are now
in a major studio rom-com the first what
does that feel like for you i mean i'm
grateful that universal and judd and
nick and billy all decided that it was a
possible thing to do
and then when i came out 15 years ago i
never thought that that would actually
get me a job
because some people said it would
actually prevent me from a job but you
know this really helped me get this job
look where you are you have a worldwide
premiere at the 47th annual toronto
international film
47th annual my friend i thank you for
that i did not know that that's wow now
you can spread that around you can thank
et canada for that as well first film i
ever did was called kinsey with liam
neeson and laura linney and i played
their son and that actually showed up at
the tiff festival and that was probably
17 years ago wow now correct me if i'm
wrong but was this your very first time
auditioning for a
studio film as far as i can remember my
first time auditioning for a studio film
as a lead
so yes yes and i mean working with billy
obviously he was all behind you for this
he wanted you in this film
what does that mean to you and how has
that friendship developed i mean i
didn't know billy that well when i met
him and it was one of those moments when
i first read the script i went like oh i
get this character and that it might be
my audition to lose
auditioning is a big part of what we do
and it's very stressful but i went into
the room with a kind of level of
confidence that i don't always have
but i knew it was a good part for me
uh has there been an audition that you
think was just absolutely something you
had you said auditions are very scary
i've been on many i hate them so much
is there one part you don't have to say
what it is that you thought you had and
you didn't no i think honestly like your
gut knows pretty well and like i say
that about many things in my career your
gut kind of knows
and when you read the script you're
usually like i might be able to force my
way into this but
your gut always knows so i don't have
any big regrets or any big flops well
you're like a hallmark king you are a
hallmark king who is now
yes i am
i've given that official title
uh
but clearly you've done a lot of
on-screen kissing that is something a
lot of hallmark films have that's right
so were you kind of taking the charge in
any scenes with billy were you like no
no no don't use tongue there i i figured
you've talked to billy so far do you get
the sense of billy lets anybody take
charge
it is always collaborative like billy
was super collaborative all the intimacy
and sex scenes with us were
kind of discovered in the moment and
we we go further than
what you might see in a hallmark film so
i'm excited i'm seeing the film right
after this but just on a serious note
you know this film does carry such a
weight it really really does i didn't
have this growing up you didn't have
this growing up and it really is so
important to have a studio support a
film like this for you just to be part
of something like this that is so
groundbreaking
what how do you even capture that
feeling of what it means to you
it's huge i mean it's huge on a lot of
levels that the studios decided to put
their money behind this and that they
believe in it and they can make some
money for them um
it's also a romantic comedy we haven't
seen those in the theaters in a really
long time so that's a really big deal
too yeah awesome it was so nice chatting
with you i think we're sitting down
tomorrow so we will we'll have a nice
little chat then
you